if you've been dying to revisit rapture  or Columbia on your current gen console  then it sounds like you might not have  to wait much longer it looks more than  likely that 2k games is working on a  bioshock collection the brazil advisory  ratings board has published a listing  from bioshock the collection which  follows the initial reveal of the  unannounced game from a South African  retailer in September 2015 the South  African retailer RAIU indicated the game  would only be coming to xbox one and ps4  but Brazil's rating includes ps3 xbox  360 and PC as well we don't know much  more about this rumored collection but  it seems likely that it will include  bioshock bioshock two and bioshock  infinite hopefully it'll also come with  all the dlc we've contacted 2k to get  more details so be sure to check out the  article on gamespot for further updates  for more on bioshock would you kindly  stay tuned to gamespot  you